[Musique]
bonjour à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de Parlement
Hebdo l'émission qui vous fait revivre
les temps forts de la semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat avec
nous sur ce plateau Bernard jaumier
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur
rattaché au groupe socialiste élu à
Paris vous êtes médecin de profession on
va faire le tour de l'actualité du
Parlement avec vous avec cette question
le Parlement va-t-il toucher à la
liberté d'installation des médecins
c'est en tout cas l'enjeu d'une
proposition de loi pour lutter contre
les déserts médicaux le texte vise à
réformer l'accès aux soins les sénateurs
ont réécrit la copie de l'Assemblée
nationale cette semaine députés et
sénateurs ont débattu de la situation
proche orient à la tribune ellisabeth
borne a de nouveau condamné les attaques
barbares du ramass tout en appelant une
trêve humanitaire les groupes politiques
ont livré leur position dans une
ambiance tendue
et puis quelle politique de
l'immigration le projet de loi tant
attendu sera débattu en novembre au
Sénat le gouvernement veut un vote avant
la fin de l'année mais pour l'instant la
droite refuse de donner son feu vert à
la régularisation dans les métiers en
tension mais on commence donc avec ce
texte sur l'accès au soins la
proposition de loi Valtou elle a été
adoptée après modification par les
sénateurs c'était mercredi soir en
séance mais face à la levée de bouclier
des médecins elle ne prévoit pas de
mesures coercitives sur l'installation
des praticiens dans les déserts médicaux
récide séance avec Adrien pin moi je
redis hélas hélas hélas une proposition
de loi adoptée sans grand enthousiasme
mercredi soir tous les bancs partagent
le sentiment d'un texte pas à la hauteur
de ses ambitions c'est une liste de
mesures qui de F leur manque de vision
globale ne règle pas règle en partie
règle une problématique mais rgle pas
l'en jeu entendez le désorir des
populations abandonnées il y a urgence à
agir au secours madame la ministre les
sénateurs ont notamment acté une
obligation des médecins du privé à faire
des gardes pour l'instant réservé aux
médecins d'hôpitaux public mais dans
l'ensemble le Sénat a largement épuré le
texte initial toutes les mesures
ambitieuses ambitieuses de ce texte ont
été rejetées dominé par la droite et le
centre la commission des affaires
sociales a supprimé les mesures qu'elle
jugeait coercitives nous avons fait un
peu de ménage le texte initial prévoyait
le rattachement automatique des médecins
libéraux à des associations locales pour
mieux organiser la per ance des soins le
Sénat a supprimé cette disposition le
débat s'est surtout enflammé autour de
la question des déserts médicaux une
centaine de sénateurs ont tenté de
réguler l'installation des médecins une
mesure portée par Emmanuel Macron dans
son programme en 2022 leurs amendements
ont été rejetés par crainte d'un
déconventionnement massif et d'un
découragement des étudiants les jeunes
il faut les inciter les inviter à aller
voir la pratique dans un hôpital de
proximité dans un territoire sousd dan
ça n'est pas en votant une mesure qui
risque de produire un effet fa délé
terire sur la jeune génération que cela
va faire avancer les choses bien au
contraire la proposition de loi est
vivement critiquée par les syndicats de
médecins lutter contre les déserts
médicaux devient un jeu d'équilibriste
et la rapporteur du texte s'est fait la
porte-voie des médecins nous
n'assurerons pas un juste accès aux
soins par des
improvisations menées contre les
médecins face au gouvernement et à la
droite la gauche a haussé le ton oui non
mais vous secouez la tête mais nous nous
ne savons plus quoi dire à à nos
concitoyens lorsque l'exercice libéral
ne répond plus alors la puissance
publique doit reprendre son rôle et
organiser les choses les sénateurs ont
toutefois valider quelques mesures
symboliques parmi elles
l'expérimentation d'une option santé au
lycée dans les déserts médicaux le
parcours de la proposition de loi n'est
pas terminé sénateurs et députés doivent
encore trouver un compromis en
commission mixte paritaire alors voilà
le Sénat qui réécrit et qui adopte la
proposition de loi Valtou la gauche les
socialistes vous avez voté contre ce
texte alors le l'idée du du laosition de
c'était d'avoir un meilleur accès au
soins pourquoi avoir voté contre bah
parce que l'idée ne se pas transformer
dans le texte en mesure convaincante et
que ce texte était ni fait ni AFF faire
malheureusement parce que justement il
rate sa cible c'est un texte qui fait
suite au texte précédent qui date d' y a
à peine 6 mois la loi dite Rist 2 qu'on
a adopté au Sénat en juillet si ma
mémoire est bonne et là 4 mois plus tard
revient avec un nouveau texte qui
affiche cette ambition de répondre aux
déserts médicaux mais la seule mesure
peut-être un peu utile enfin je veux
dire significative c'est le partage de
la permanence des soins entre les
hôpitaux publics et les cliniques
privées le reste alors on y vient on y
vient mais justement la question
centrale c'est celle des déserts
médicaux avec ce ce totem de la liberté
d'installation des médecins euh
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous en
dites vous êtes médecin vous-même est-ce
qu'il faut toucher ou pas à ce qui est
vu comme un totem presque un tabou
liberté d'installation du médecin on
meurt en politique des totems et des
tabou et des symboles et des la question
c'est est-ce que c'est efficace vous
avez quelques pourcent du territoire qui
sont surdotés enfin suffisamment ou
largement doté personne ne propose de
retirer les médecins qui sont dans ces
territoires pour les envoyer ailleurs
personne ce qui est proposé c'est
d'interdire aux jeunes de s'y installer
mais quel effet ça va avoir vous avez
trois 4 % de territoire surdoté vous en
avez 87 % qui sont sous-dotés donc vous
pouvez dire aux jeunes non vous vous
installerez pas là mais c'est une
poignée chaque année à ce rythme là dans
30 ans on n'ura pas résolu la question
donc il faut être sérieux je veux bien
qu'on qu'on et c'est dangereux vous
savez de mettre sur la table des mesures
dont on sait qu'elles sont inefficaces
mais parce qu'on prend une posture
politique parce que derrière il y a pas
de résultat et derrière il y a encore
plus de colère et d'exaspération et moi
je comprends la colère et l'exaspération
des personnes qui n'arrivent plus à
avoir accès à un médecin en séance une
centaine de sénateurs de droite comme de
gauche ont tenté par des amendements et
ben de revenir sur de réguler
l'installation des médecins les
amendements ont tous été repoussés alors
on l'entendait dans le reportage c'est
la crainte d'un déconventionnement
massif des médecins aussi le signal de
défiance envoyé aux étudiants de
médecine mais est-ce qu'on peut le dire
assez simplement le le lobby des
médecins a gagné contre le lobby des
élus locaux non moi je vois pas du tout
les choses comme ça et vous savez
d'ailleurs parfois ce sont les mêmes je
vous le je vous le rappelle la seule
question qui vaille c'est celle de
l'accès de notre population aux soins si
c'était efficace d'interdire aux jeunes
d'aller s'installer à Cannes ou à biarid
enfin dans très peu d'endroits comme ça
moi je voterai cette mesure sans
hésitation alors qu'est-ce que vous
proposez la place vous savez la
difficulté c'est que c'est forcément
long et complexe je vais vous prendre un
exemple c'est les oftalmo et la filière
visu u la situation est en train de
s'améliorer très nettement les délais
baissent pourquoi parce qu'il y a
quasiment 10 ans on a commencé à
réorganiser cette filière à mettre en
place des responsabilités
supplémentaires pour les orthoptistes à
mettre en place d'ailleurs des des
centres où vous voyez un orthoptiste et
vous ne voyez l'optalmo que quelques
minutes si votre problème est simple et
donc à gagner du temps d'ophtalmologiste
et ça produit des effets puisque les
délais sont en train de se réduire je
dit pas qu'ils sont satisfaisants ils
sont en train de se réduire sur les
médecins généralistes puis que c'est
beaucoup ça le problème dans l'accès aux
soins de proximité c'est il y a question
des spécialités mais c'est le médecin
généraliste ça pose beaucoup de problème
le dispositif des assistants médicaux il
en est où c'est très long à mettre en
place les infirmières de pratique avancé
en ambulatoire qui que que que les
syndicats de médecins réclament pour la
plupart 200 à peine 200
on ne finance pas leur formation il
faudrait en en former 10000 très
rapidement donc payer leur formation
leur permettre de s'installer tous ces
dispositifs qui visent à partager les
soins à faire monter en puissance des
professions qui ont une démographie
favorable les infirmières les kinés sont
très nombreux les sages-femmes et bien
tout ça est beaucoup trop lent il y a
beaucoup trop peu de volontarisme il
faut un dispositif santé et territoire
qui soit complet et qui soit rapide une
dernière question sur ce texte avant
d'aller sur le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale mais
on voit d'autres mesures comme par
exemple l'encadrement de l'intérim
médical la suppression du certificat
médical avec à la place un certificat
sur l'honneur pour les les absence en
cas d'enfant malad ou encore une option
santé dans les lessé pour créer des
vocations il y a quand même des choses
intéressantes dans cette proposition de
loi oui alors la question des
certificats médicaux on a voté
d'ailleurs hein cet article là ça va
beaucoup simplifier la vie des parents
ça oui ça ça ça va permettre de gagner
un peu de temps et cetera donc toutes
ces mesures de simplification sont
bonnes à prendre et on les vote
d'ailleurs mais après tout un ensemble
de mesures est totalement inutile alors
on parle du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale 2024 qui était à
l'ordre du jour qui est à l'ordre du
jour à l'Assemblée nationale mais
Bernard jaumier le débat tourné court en
tout cas ellisabeth borne a déclenché un
nouveau 493 sur la partie les premières
parties de ce budget après une série de
revers est-ce que s'il n'avit pas
utilisé le 493 le gouvernement aurait pu
faire autrement quelle est l'alternative
finalement alors ce scénario qui se
répète sur l'épisode budgétaire oui mais
si le budget de la Sécurité sociale
enfin la première partie n'a même pas
été adopté en commission c'est peut-être
qu'il est très mauvais et quand vous
regardez la gestion par le gouvernement
de la sécurité sociale le budget qui
nous présente non seulement il est
déficitaire mais il est déficitaire sur
les 5 années à venir la première option
politique qu'on doit prendre sur le
budget de la sécurité é sociale je le
dis c'est de le ramener à l'équilibre il
était quasiment à l'équilibre en
2017-28 quand Emmanuel Macron a été élu
chef de l'État alors il y a eu la crise
covid depuis le gouvernement semble dire
le contraire il se tardque de faire des
des mesures
d'économie ah bon bah oui mais c'est pas
ce que disent ces tableaux de chiffres 8
milliards de déficit à neuv sur
l'assurance maladie en 2024 et 11
l'année suivante donc le gouvernement en
fait laisse la sécurité sociale en cite
et ça s'explique très simplement
d'ailleurs ne donne pas de perspective
positive or la sécurité sociale est un
bien précieux pour les Français et là
laissé en déficit c'est envoyer au pays
le message que tout ça coûte cher et
donc il faut réduire les dépenses c'est
ça la logique et bien moi je suis
heureux que les membres de la commission
des affaires sociales de l'Assemblée a
dit non à cette option politique et le
débat n'est pas fini on va changer de
sujet l'actualité internationale a
bouleversé l'ordre du jour du Parlement
un débat a eu lieu à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat sur la situation
au Proche Orient Élisabeth borne a redit
le soutien de la France à Israël en
appelant toutefois une trêve humanitaire
à Gaza débat sans vote réclamé par tous
il n'y avait pas foule mais beaucoup de
tension en séance comme nous le raconte
Stéphanie
Despierre dans un hémicycle à moitié
vide ellisabeth borne peine à se faire
entendre en prononçant ces
mots d'un ban à l'autre les députés
s'invectivent en prononçant ces mots je
v plaî mes chers collèges madame la
Première ministre la veille le tweet de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon contre la visite de
yel Bron PIV en Israël a encore accentué
les tensions françaises je tiens madame
la Présidente personnellement à vous
apporter mon plus entier soutien suite
aux attaques intolérables dont vous avez
pu faire l'objet ces derniers jours
j'affirme ici mon soutien à la
présidente de notre assemblée après
l'attaque abjecte dont elle a été la
cible hier
la première ministre fustige une fois
encore les déclarations des insoumis sur
cette guerre entre Israël et le Hamas
nous ne devons faire preuve d'aucune
ambigué face à de tels crimes ceux qui
confondent le droit des Palestiniens à
disposer d'un état et la justification
du terrorisme commettent une faute
morale politique et
stratégiqueabeth borne réclame une trêve
humanitaire et réaffirme la position
historique de la France maisans
la PR ministre la France autrefois voie
de et entre vos mains devenu un
état aligné aligné sur les États-Unis et
sur le gouvernement israélien VAT en
guerre d'extrême droite ministre madame
au Sénat le lendemain le climat est bien
plus apaisé la première ministre
confirme le déblocage d'une aide
humanitaire supplémentaire pour les
Palestiniens les République en la mett
en garde pas un euro ne doit aller à une
organisation de type terroriste comme le
Hanas pas 1 € les communistes eux
insistent sur le respect du droit
international nous ne pouvons accepter
que l'État d'Israël que le gouvernement
de Monsieur netaniaou passe du droit à
se défendre à un droit de se venger
c'est la position de la France
qu'Emmanuel Macron rappelait presque au
même moment en Israël alors justement
Bernard Jes petite question sur la
position de la France qui sent qui tente
de maintenir une sorte d'équilibre entre
soutien sans faille à Israël d'un côté
mais aussi appelle à une trêve itire
est-ce que pour vous cette position
française est claire et cohérente
oui euh dans la dimension d'abord d'un
commentaire sans ambiguïté sur l'attaque
du 7 octobre l'attaque du 7 octobre
c'est une attaque barbare d'un groupe
terroriste et s'il y a une telle
différence je pense entre l'hémicyle de
l'Assemblée nationale et CELI du Sénat
c'est que dans l' mytiques du Sénat tous
les groupes politiques ont condamné sans
essayer de
B de contextualiser absolument cette
attaque barbare ça c'est la photo et
quand quand survient un événement comme
ça effectivement vous prenez position
sur cette photo le problème c'est que
les insoumis ont voulu contextualiser
tout de suite c'est-à-dire regarder le
film ce qui se passe depuis plusieurs
décennies pour ce qui est de l'histoire
contemporain er mais c'est plus qu'une
erreur enfin c'est c'est une infamie
quand vous faites de la politique vous
commencez par affirmer des valeurs des
valeurs d'humanité si vous ne partagez
pas ces valeurs d'humanité vous ne
pouvez pas partager des d'autres combats
politique et donc la France a en portant
cette condamnation sans faiblir de ce
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre puis en
rappelant et moi je me félicite que la
diplomatie française rappelle que la
France soutient une solution une
solution à deux états et vous savez ce
que peu relève c'est que à gauche il y a
cette fracture que tout le monde voit
mais à droite qu'est-ce qui est en train
de se passer les républicains qui sont
un mouvement qui qui avait vocation en
tout cas à gouverner le pays qui l'a
gouverné longtemps qui a défendu cette
solution à deux états et bien j'entends
le président des républicains maintenant
dérivé sur une ligne qui est une lecture
on va dire occidentaliste du conflit et
donc sur une ligne précisément de quoi
est-ce que vous parlez et bien j'ai
entendu le président des républicains
ericotti ne plus reprendre cette
solution à deux états et se ranger dans
une vision de guerre de religion de
guerre de l'Occident contre le reste du
monde sur ce conflit donc de plaqu de
plaquer cette vision idéologique sur ce
conflit et donc de quitter la position
traditionnelle de la France et c'est une
fracture profonde il me semble à droite
alors cette semaine on a vu le
déplacement du chef de l'État dans
plusieurs pays du Proche Orient après
Israël la sis Jordanie ensuite la
Jordanie et enfin l'Égypte que pensez de
sa proposition d'une coalition
internationale pour lutter contre le
Hamas avec et bien ce qui ressemblerait
à ce qui se passait contre l'État
islamique dans la région également avec
des pays arabes qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette proposition j'ai pas
comprise je n'ai pas comprise parce que
qu'est-ce qu'elle révèle euh de vouloir
à tout
prix faire croire que la France a une
influence dans la région au prix d'une
proposition iconoclaste et qui porte le
clivage que je dénonce non c'est aussi
ass des pays arabes avec des pays
occidentaux dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme vous avez vu la réponse des
pays arabes donc c'est ça n c'était mal
préparé cette proposition c'était trop
mais mais elle n' elle n'a pas de sens
enfin vous avez cessigné la dimension
pour le coup politique profonde de ce
qui se passe en Palestine et en Israël
je ve dire il y a des un peuple
palestinien il existe ses droits ont été
bafoués depuis trop longtemps l'absence
de solution politique crée un chaos et
vous avez une puissance régionale l'Iran
qui mêle à ce ce conflit local une
dimension religieuse une dimension
islamiste et là vous avez tout un espèce
d'amalgame qui se constitue et vous
aveit en France des lectures politiques
qui ont l'air satisfait de cet amalgame
qui le porent alors qu'il est dangereux
alors qu'il est dangereux c'est pour ça
qu'il faut en revenir à la position
équilibrée traditionnellement celle de
la France on en on en est loin le
problème le problème vous avz dit il est
complexe global mais est-ce que vous
pensez pas quand même que la France ces
gouvernements successifs ont un peu
abandonné le Proche Orient à son sort en
tout cas on a Clement la communauté
internationale le Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies c'est clairement trop
mis en retrait c'est trop désintéressé
de la situation au Proche Orient et on a
je pense donné l'impression c'est
peut-être pas qu'une impression de ne
pas condamner suffisamment la dérive du
gouvernement israélien Benyamin net vous
savez rappelez-vous quand AC Rabine a
été assassiné lui qui portait un vrai
processus de paix il a été assassiné par
un extrémiste juif et bien si cette ce
jeune extrémiste était vivant
aujourd'hui il serait probablement dans
les mouvements politiques auquel
beniamine Netanyahou est associé au
gouvernement et ça c'est grave et nous
avons laissé faire nous n'avons pas
parlé est suffisamment fort la voix de
la France s'est éteinte tranquillement
peut-être parce que il y avait d'autres
priorités mais le résultat c'est que ce
conflit ancien se rappelle brutalement à
nous Bernard jaumier on en vient au
dernier thème dans cette émission le
projet de loi immigration il arrive à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat ce sera le 6
novembre il a été plusieurs fois
repoussé depuis un an un an et demi les
tensions sont fortes autour de ce texte
même si le gouvernement espère un vote
d'ici la fin de l'année mais au cœur des
tensions il y a l'article 3 v voyez la
position du chef de fil des centristes
au Sénat Hervé
Marseille les républicains sont d'accord
avec nous pour dire on peut rectifier
tout ça par voie circulaire c'est la
circulaire Vals on la rectifie bon très
bien le seul point le seul point c'est
que dans l'article dans un article de la
loi l'article 3 ou un autre on puisse
dire qu'on va changer la circulaire
parce qu'à la sememblé il y a des gens
qui vous disent s'il y a pas ça on vote
pas et eux ils disent si on le met on
vote pas problème c'est de savoir si on
veut ou si on veut pas que ce texte soit
voté ça c'est un autre sujet mais il
faut assumer à ce moment-là voilà
l'article 3 on le rappelle c'est cet
article sur la régularisation des sans
papiers dans les secteurs dans les
métiers en tension qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de toute cette tension autour de
ce projet de loi immigration qui est un
long feuilleton on le disait ça fait
plus d'un an qu'il est dans les tuyaux
ce texte oui puis vous le savez ça doit
être la 28 29e loi en 30 ans je ne sais
plus exactement 2e depuis 19 merci merci
donc voilà donc en une trentaine
d'années euh et je crois il y a il y a
un point auquel je souscris tout à fait
dans ce que dit Hervé Marseille c'est
qu'au fond on n pas vraiment besoin
d'une loi pour sur cette question là
donc cette volonté à tout prix de
légiférer sans cesse est une volonté de
posture poétique et moi ce qui me marque
quand vous lisez la loi lisez juste les
titres de chaque article c'est une loi
de peur relativement aux étrangers c'est
une loi de repli sur So pourquant de
tumultte autour de ce fameux article 3
si on peut déjà régulariser par d'autres
voies notamment par la voix de de la
CIRC parce unee partie une partie du
monde politique à droite à l'extrême
droite et une partie de la majorité
présidentielle mais j'espère que ce
n'est qu'une minorité a des réaction de
rejet vis-à-vis d'étrangers qui sont
présents sur notre sol et qui ne posent
aucun problème les mêmes qui vont le
soir au restaurant et sont contents du
repas qu'il font ne vont pas ouvrir la
porte de la cuisine il verraent derrière
des étranger qui font la cuisine qui
mènent une vie paisible qui se lèv tôt
le matin qui travaillent tard le soir et
qui ne demande qu'une chose c'est qu'on
reconnaisse simplement ce qu'ils font
dans notre pays et pour notre pays et
bien les mêmes prennent des postures qui
sont sur cet article 3 de dire ah non on
peut pas les régulariser on va faire un
appel d'air c'est faux on sait que c'est
faux ça n'existe pas est-ce qu'il y a
une impasse politique pour le
gouvernement avec à la fois l'il gauche
de la macronie qui tient à cet article 3
les LR qui en font une ligne rouge
absolu les centristes qui essayent de
trouver un compromis entre tout le monde
il y a une impasse politique pour
géralde d'Anin vous le pensez bah on
verra bien s'il arrive à s'en sortir
mais il s'y est mis tout seul enfin le
gouvernement s'est mis dans cet impasse
il n'y avait absolument aucune nécessité
de légiférer sur cette question et si
vous regardez l'ensemble du texte il ne
il ne porte que des points qui sont des
points de rejet d'étranger y compris
vous savez quand vous êtes étranger en
France à foruris' il n'y a plus cet
article 3 dans le texte vous dit à force
sur il n'y a plus mais mais de toute
façon vous avez d'autres articles qui
portent sur les étrangers malades ou sur
la carte talent puisqu'on parlait de de
santé ce qui est tout à fait marquant
c'est que en fait on ne veut plus des
étrangers malades dans notre pays mais
par contre on veut prendre les médecins
de des
pays du Sud enfin c'est on est un pays
qui se REP de rejet des étrangers c'est
un texte de peur de repli et de rejet et
c'est absolument pas à la hauteur de ce
qui'est notre pays notre pays change oui
le monde change et vouloir penser que on
va revenir parce que c'est ce qu'il y a
derrière tout ça se mêle avec évidemment
le terrorisme islamiste c'est ça qui est
mêlé dans ce texte quand vous lisez les
amendements que dépose nos certains
collègues de droite sur ce texte on voit
le mélange des thèmes et bien c'est un
pays qui qui a peur qui se replie et qui
pense qu'il va revenir aux années 50 ou
mais maintenant dans les années 50 pour
pour venir en France ramercer la
Méditerranée c'était très compliqué
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus simple
mais retirer un titre de séjour à une
personne qui ne respecte pas les valeurs
de la République puisque je crois que
c'est ça qui est exactement dans le
texte à l'article 10 ça c'est du c'est
du bon sens
non le respect des valeurs la public
c'est ce qu'on peut attendre d'une
personne bien sûr mais après il faut le
définir précisément et quand je vous dis
mais il y a quelques dispositions dans
ce texte qui sont tout à fait
acceptables hein je vous ne dis pas que
la philosophie mais la philosophie du
texte est détestable et vous parlez de
ne pas respecter valeurs de la
République j'ai lu des amendements qui
proposent de retirer les titres de ces
jour ou de ne pas accepter de
régulariser quelqu'un qui a commis une
faute mineure que vous moi tout le monde
peut connaître déin voilà donc on est on
est bien dans une lecture politique qui
est très très très une lecture de peur
qui est destiné probablement à
satisfaire ou à empêcher l'extrême
droite de se développer je ne sais pas O
ça en est mais toujours est-il que nous
nous combattons fermement cette ligne
parce qu'elle n'est pas à la hauteur de
ce qui'est la France alors on voit bien
que ce sera compliqué pour le
gouvernement en tout cas le débat n'a
pas encore commencé est-ce que si les
choses sont mal engagées pour le
gouvernement vous pensez qu'il peut
recourir un nouveau 493 et il sera
précieux celui-là puisqu'on est plus
dans le débat budgétaire donc il grille
une cartouche se ou la seule de la
session je je pense que utiliser la
procédure du 493 c'est-à-dire
empêcher le Parlement de délibérer au
fond sur une question aussi importante
pas pour dire que le budget n'est pas
important mais sur une question
sociétalement aussi importante sera un
formidable aveu d'échec pour le
gouvernement c'est que il n'est pas en
situation de faire comprendre et de
faire partager sa ligne politique par ne
serait-ce que sa propre majorité parce
que c'est ça que ça signifiera on voit
bien que la majorité présidentielle
elle-même est divisée sur ce texte donc
il se sera mis lui-même dans l'échec et
ce sera un échec sur l'échec très
rapidement il nous reste 30 secondes la
transformation d'une aide médicale
d'État en aide médicale d'urgence comme
sans doute la droite va le voter au
Sénat et comme Gérald haranin s dit
favorable personnellement qu'est-ce que
ça vous évoque ça m'évoque ce dont je
parleris c'est-à-dire que les
républicains sont en pour une partie
d'entre eux sont en perte de valeur
totale c'est un dispositif de santé
publique refuser de soigner les gens
c'est simplement le renimement de ce qu'
a été la position des rblain depuis des
décennies et ce sera le mot de la fin
Bernard jaier sénateur et par ailleurs
vous êtes médecin je le rappelle merci
d'avoir été l'invité de cette édition de
Parlement Hebdo on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à très
[Musique]
vite